(gentle music)
- [Narrator] How is it doing that?
Hamsters, like Soda
Pop, can stuff up to 20%
of their body weight into their cheeks.
For comparison, that's
like the average person
carrying around 30 extra pounds of food,
or about 120 quarter pounders.
It would be a cool party
trick, but not very comfortable
or, let's face it, even possible.
That's where hamsters are different.
But they don't stuff
their faces for parties,
or even because they're hungry.
They do it to survive.
In the wild, yes, there
are actually wild hamsters,
they eat all kinds of food, leaves,
shoots, veggies, and fruit.
What they don't consume right away,
they store in those
cheeks, which have pouches
that extend half way down their body
and expand like a balloon.
Thank goodness we don't
have anything like that,
because it would probably
look a little strange.
But hamsters need to stuff their faces
no matter how goofy it might look.
In fact, they have to eat
around every two hours
to function normally, but
foraging for food this frequently
would make them easy prey.
Instead, they collect food at night,
and what they don't store,
they snack on along the way.
So during the day they
can hide from predators
and munch on their hoard in safety.
And thanks to the pouches in their cheeks,
that stockpile can get enormous.
Hamster burrows have been found
with nearly 200 pounds of stored food.
These cheeks also come with
special retractor muscles
that help the hamster stuff
itself to maximum capacity.
If you ever watch this
in action, you may notice
that it reorients the food
after plopping it in its mouth.
What it's actually doing is
angling the food so it easily
slips to the back of the
pouch as more comes in.
Once the food is well on its way,
that's when the retractor
muscles come into play.
When the pouch stretches,
the muscles contract,
which pushes the food toward the back,
preventing it from clogging up.
Pretty impressive stuff.
But that's not as impressive
as some of the other things
hamsters can do with their cheeks.
For starters, some species
will hide their babies
inside these pouches to keep them safe.
There are reports that others
can inflate their pouches
with air and use it as a
flotation device for swimming.
But don't try this at home.
Only certain wild species do this,
and we don't want you to
drown your poor hamster.
We'd rather have you sit
and enjoy the incredible
cuteness of Soda Pop.
Here's a fun fact.
Hamsters can run over five
miles in a 24-hour period.
(gentle music)